[Musica]
come estate ragazzi che sappiate che
ogni venerdì 13 è sempre un giorno un po
speciale perché in genere è il giorno in
cui porto sul canale enel t13 che dà un
sacco che non lo porto quindi buon
venerdì 13 a tutti ragazzi e cominciamo
con l'episodio di oggi allora l'unione
fa la forza e quindi stiamo tutti qua
vicini perché se non ce l'abbiamo per
lui
ecco appunto allora fa mi chiude quasi
fame chiude a chiave
joe alla mappa cielo che non mi ricordo
si ce l'ho già la mappa la macchina equa
per i ragazzi la macchina sta qua quindi
troviamo le chiavi o la mensa insomma
qualsiasi cosa non so che cosa visto che
non possiamo parlare con la chat spero e
prego
proprio lui giocatori number one di
venerdì 13 ragazzi proprio grazie mille
ecco anche pietro vale ai ragazzi
prossima partita speriamo di non essere
c'è insomma perché non c'ho voglia meno
male allora che poi comunque quello che
stavo dicendo è quello che avrebbe detto
anche dal titolo per i treni c è una
mong as che non ha mai smesso di
crederci alla fine c'è un impostore
sarebbe gelo e tutti gli altri che
devono sopravvivere ma con la differenza
che tu l'impostore sei già chi è sempre
il gelato in allungarsi l'impostore
maledetto prove
among us in tempi di halloween
venerdì 13 ragazzi quindi avevano già
inventato quindi portiamo tutti
l'impostore e proviamo a vedere se
riusciamo a scappare col trattore ma
sociali ma perché non riesco a trovarne
le chiavi qualcosa ecco qua un buono
pistola buono buono anch'io la pistola
buona ragala pistole buona mi servono
assolutamente le chiavi della macchina
che se anche non so neanche dove la
macchina va bene fate vedere un attimo
ragazzi allora lama due macchine io
andrei su questa qua perché mi sembra la
più vicina a risorse visto che c'è la
casa enorme che è praticamente subito vi
di bianco
dobbiamo assolutamente trovare le chiavi
che la cosa più difficile da trovare in
tutto il gioco ovviamente i cassetti
puoi stare anche tutto il giorno niente
porca vacca al walkie talkie vedeva
niente premio niente chiavi ragazzi dai
vi prego una mezza anche solo mezza
chiave mezza chiave non ci capisco
incastrato nel perfetto ci ha messo
qualcosa e si cassetti ma sono tutti i
vuoti non vale qua c'è niente con ho
preso l'unica o l'unica casa nel gioco
ragazzi non fanno così schifo le carte
nei giorni del gioco c'è veramente ho
preso l'unica che non ha niente ma
neanche un cassetto con qualcosa dentro
sciamani nulla felice di constatare
direttamente dove sta la gente anche se
effettivamente molto più sicuro perché
jason qua non ci verrebbe mai
quindi a questo punto ragazzi mi faccio
se trecase me le faccio tutte e tre
tanto jason quando non dovrebbe venire
perché sono mega distante dagli altri
quindi usa la radio per chiamare tommy
jarvis
per adesso siamo a posto con la radio
quindi se qualcuno muore diventa tommy
jarvis
spero di non essere io alla radio o lana
la batteria
ma chi e radio 80 una batteria dalla
macchia che culo va bene è un pezzo del
sud 3 dalla macchina ce l'abbiamo da via
se è tutto a posto ragazzi è solo la
voce rauca che fa questo effetto non c'è
niente di male se riesco se riuscissi a
trovare le chiavi saremmo a cavallo
perché avrei due pezzi su tre
teoricamente non è né non sarebbe
neanche tanto vale come situazione
effettivamente però proviene dalla
aggiunge qualcuno la parata di star e
jason call con gli scopi articoli
miniciccioli che ciò anch'io
me ne sbatto ragazzi e pro vedere se
riesco a trovare altri pezzi
facciamo finta di nulla jason non esiste
non esiste jason è un'invenzione
nonostante gli anni passati giusto gioco
ancora ragazzi fatico a capire se le
chiavi o comunque tutti gli oggetti
sparlano effettivamente in più tra ma
forse c'è la possibilità che non stavano
proprio ho sempre avuto straw dubbio non
ho mai capito prova vera che allora ho
tutto quello che mi serve per adesso non
so se andare verso alle chiavi soli
ragazzi ci sono le chiavi sopra ci sono
le chiavi di sopra le vedo sono qua
quindi ci sono hanno trovato le chiavi
per terra quindi c'è un morto
sì già morto assassinato un boom si
chiama faccio un bordello di case però
teoricamente cei sen
non dovrebbe essere qua che esco
bordello sento come se ci fosse gente ma
non c'è gente e la cosa mi inquieta
tantissimo ma dov'è aiuto chase qua
vicino non capisco dove ragazzi però
credo sia qua perché vedo teletrasporti
9 a un corpo morto ma chi se ne frega
dei pm che giovinco cui ho detto o ho
preso un po di roba raga utile via via
via fuori dalle balle non so neanche
dove sto andando raga me ne sbatto le
vale allora la macchina sta qua sopra
ossia le chiavi che la batteria se per
caso qualcuno ha già messo la tanica
siamo a cavallo però dubito l'altro cesa
non avrà messo ovviamente le trappole
sulla macchina che io non potrò
disinnescare quindi un casino
vediamo una mano capolini non c'è già ma
non è vero non ci voglio che la dice già
la batteria
ma veramente l'unica roba che ho trovata
la batteria c'è già la batteria ma
veramente c'era già ma l'unica una volta
che trova che molto più rara della
tanica la batteria quello il fatto che
sono tutti all'altra macchina tra
l'altro all'altra mentre sono tutti
all'altra macchina vediamo se io riesco
a cavarmela da solo
io non uso gli altri questa partita non
solo non e compagni sono tutti
dall'altra parte quindi credo e spero
che jason sia andato dall'altra parte
ciò mi dovrebbe dare abbastanza margine
di ricerca della tanica visto che tutti
sono d'altra parte degli jason sarà qua
quindi speriamo iddio di trovare una tac
se per caso la tanica ce l'hanno loro
chi vedo jason che sta seguendo la
eccola la tanica ce l'hanno qua la
tanica gli ho le chiavi zio
io ho le chiavi quindi se mettete la
tanica mentre jane doe che vi sta
rincorrendo che non potete farlo
ovviamente
io provo a mettere la batteria sta qua
io ce l'ho io manca la batteria però
anche manca tutto in staccate di
macchina devo andare a prendere la
batteri un casino raga non fare un giro
totale mana chuma non potevate prendere
le cose tutte insieme
la tansione se io prendo natali che me
ne vado non raga fermi pagina provata
nora camica se riesco a tornare alla
macchina non riesco ma se riesco zio ti
prego non mi distrarre in questo momento
non so dove sia gente non masse riesco
ad allontanarmi eccola ti prego apice
jesolo mista lontano dove recuperare un
po di energia si sta zitto non ti
capisco se devo sperare iddio che jason
non entri non mi sbloccare a porta ma
vai via
stavo vuole quest'altro a buy via e ci
aiuta visse decesso amico mino chirico a
maledizione alla vita
cesar amico mio io non voglio mettere la
tanica non la voglio mettere chi
ricordava il mio compagno sa che lascia
stare è niente sono troppo per terra e
cavani ma mai al vicolo è giovanna così
fratelli che sfiga peccato perché non
c'e la volevo proprio mettere la thema
pena cosa vedo va bene è finita mi
dispiace perché ho trovato tutto ciò è
votato la tanica curami sapere peccato
volevo andare dall'altra parte io
mannaggia che sfiga va bene conclusione
del video ragazzi specie bello storia di
13 però vi sia piaciuto ischia idea
chiara ragazzi che mi piace e noi come
sempre ci vediamo l'anno prossimo video
bella ragazza
[Musica]